[Music]
awake
again
it seems there is no stopping spain's
kumbreva volcanic flow
earlier the giant crater fell silent
leaving an eerie calm in what were once
lively coastal villages it has caused so
much destruction
homes and memories of generations of
families living on the volcano's
foothill charred by the swelling and
pouring lava as it inches towards the
ocean
how to explain this loss to her
grandchildren wonders andrea rodriguez
concepcion
the truth is i'm very sad
everyone is losing their homes the
volcano keeps me up at night this is a
shock to all of us
panicked villagers are fleeing others
are staying put despite the dangers
almost 7 000 people are displaced and
cannot return to their homes it is very
unpredictable
the situation is very tense and calm at
the same time so this is this uh
to manage this stress
in a very long race because this is not
a speed race for us uh we are going to
work for weeks with them
is the most difficult thing
experts fears what will happen when the
lava of 1000 degrees celsius reaches the
cold atlantic ocean a haze of toxic
chemicals made up of sulfur dioxide
hydrochlorine and volcanic acid will
fill the air this is likely to cause
skin and eye irritation
breathing the fumes can be fatal
shipping vessels have been advised to
stay clear of the area to avoid being
exposed to potential acid rainfalls
there is no escaping volcanic activity
on the island of la palma look right
behind me blowing in the sky is a cloud
of ash from cumbria vieja and we're in
the south west of the island here
authorities have even started recording
seismic activity with tremors gaining
intensity putting at risk this small
village of fuen caliente
on the edge of the cliff fuen calientes
tourist hotels have become shelters for
the displaced schools are shut with
authorities in the area calling on
people to stay indoors
andrea watches powerless an unfolding
tragedy rattled by the powerful sound of
nature
tonight again
she will not sleep
nicholas hawk al jazeera foreign la
palma spain